foreign
thank you
hello it's good to be here at other
people a live dating show where we watch
people date each other out of a bucket
it's like real life Tinder if there was
less dick pics and more sad
stories about dicks
well my name is Hans Kim I am a Serial
Vader I've had three girlfriends in my
whole life so you can see a bit of an
expert on her subject
um I'll be a part of my wisdom along
with the guests here tonight a very
funny comedian Chicago New York she's
passing the cellar give it up for the
very funny Amy shaker
hi Amy hi how are you
hello good how are you oh [ __ ] the front
row looks nice yeah we got a front row
tonight yeah look at that the front row
is the second Road tonight
the front row looks like my dating life
look how happy this guy got when you
said that like
yeah yeah yeah so I was dating in Austin
um dating in Austin
hey come on turn the woman's mic on
always trying always trying to silence
hey white man
Austin does silence
oh now it works it works now thank you
Nick I'm gonna let it work for those
people though I'm gonna keep this one
okay how's dating in Austin it's
interesting
oh it's um
I don't know I don't um I dated someone
here for a little while but then he was
like I've never had feelings for you and
I was like okay well that sucks I think
we were dating a tech bro
should I no that that was a tech but he
has no why is it attack bro yeah no I I
wish man because then it would make
sense
he's just a robot I'm dating a robot
yeah I didn't realize you were Grimes
I don't even know who that is
[Music]
well you know some of these references
are just for the uh nerds in the room
you know
for that hey this guy is cheering again
this is Amy schenker's biggest autistic
fan
[Laughter]
I can't I'm gonna
I'm single I'll start dating well so far
we got a bunch of men signed up and
about three women
that's so Austin this is this is Austin
dating in Austin in a nutshell
a lot of nuts not enough
[ __ ]
um
we got Matt lava coming up Matt Lama
make your way on up here buddy oh here
he is going up the stairs right over
there I like the the wind in the room
the wind yes this is great for little
scraps of paper
hi Matt I might forget your name and if
you're a woman please sign up men we
don't really need you
is this
is a non-gendered microphone they're
used by both genders Matt Lama how are
you doing tonight I'm doing well Hans
how are you I'm doing great you got
really cool glasses on what's the story
behind those glasses
well I've had really messed up eyes my
whole entire life okay that's sad
um
what about the design of them that's a
choice to get into that I'm a collector
of eyeglasses oh
born by your I feel like he takes them
from victims though
is this your calling card
with a spectacled murderer his trinkets
killing it with the designer eyewear
getting started with a serial killer
accusations early
it's tough to be a man out there
yeah you guys have it really hard
let's just see our victims yeah uh we
got Marley L coming up
Harley l oh here she is coming from
right next to you is that a pink top I
love pink coming from right next to Matt
llamas is a friend of Matt llamas
it's Marley pleasure to meet you
going on a date for 90 seconds starting
now
so what are you most afraid of when it
comes to the Future
well I'm pregnant
that's kind of scary
you're afraid of being a mom or afraid
of the future that the child will come
into kind of
books she's having a girl
did your man was was he actually like
excited though
because
no it's the woman microphone
back to my question was your man friend
excited about having a girl because all
guys want another them
well he's been pulling out since you
know forever
this time it didn't work
hauling out
polling polling out
that method
so tell me something about you
well we've been married for almost four
years okay so there is that
have you ever given anyone chlamydia
as a matter of fact this pregnant chick
next to me I gave chlamydia too
and time give it up for Mad llamas
a vector of disease
and
the other person
Marley L how dare you disrespect my wife
on her birthday I'm the one that I'm not
the one that gave her chlamydia dude
I'm so just one pill one pill how how uh
how did you not know you had chlamydia
explain this yes of course pick up the
man microphone and explain it
[Music]
and signed up for Tinder and had 17
females that he was hooking up with
wow females that's some nerd [ __ ] right
there
you got the [ __ ] you got all these
phones out you're just swiping away you
got the system worked out with your
glasses stable gotta have a stable of
hoes
you're trying to say you were you were
stable I was like no you're not dude for
sure
very unhinged Behavior
not hinge I was getting to it but thank
you
um
uh what was your name Marley so how did
that make you feel after you got
chlamydia you were like this is a guy
that's gonna have my babies
well I didn't talk to him for a couple
weeks and then he confessed how much he
loved me and hated everyone else that he
was with and couldn't vacation with so
he asked for me back
wow he hates
me
a pandemic of white women
um
[Music]
so you guys uh said some very
interesting things on your date you said
have you ever seen teenage girls
why are you trying to get your man to
look at teenage girls
I was going to say something but that's
wrong I would say I do them for a living
but I do their hair for a living you did
the hair for a living yeah so you you're
that's they all want to be blonde
yeah
no
yeah that's cool so you make them more
like you you're creating a master race
of Aryan teenagers
right outside Disney World
that's cool you're making everyone
blonde so your your point was like it's
hard to be a teenage girl and you're
you're about to have one are you nervous
about your future teenage girls hair
I'm too far along yeah
well not in not in California you aren't
you're one Southwest flight from this
not being a problem
[Laughter]
[Music]
she wanted to ride a bird scooter here I
had to shut that down
you know if you fall
yes
okay
tune in next week for the conclusion to
this
horrible pregnancy
I was really hoping for a boy
which was that I don't want a girl
yeah no I'm becoming more excited about
the prospect of being a girl dad well
don't get too excited
because he might molest it
what do you think your child will
identify as it has one option
you're calling it it too now
it's a she
it is a shoe we had a gender reveal
party
there was a Tic Tac Tic Tac Toe Board of
Disney princesses and princes and we had
to match it super super yeah
yes we did oh we did
yeah we put on my tick tock
[Music]
it is because it comes all the way down
to the last like turning of the
tic-tac-toe so I'm guessing you lost and
that's why it's a girl
that's how he always looks
he didn't have his glasses on
the [ __ ]
yeah
but that was it was like you were there
with that reaction like
you're like I wanted a little version I
wanted a little version of me like every
guy wants yeah because I got it so wrong
so I want to make sure that I could
write that wrong
no being like a masculine dude right
like I wanted my baby to be like a bro
I
agree with that
so you want your son to be able to beat
you up
in an Ideal World yes
why would you want that
that way I know when he goes out into
the world he can assert dominance
anywhere he goes and get arrested I
always had a problem get arrested in
Romania
thank you
what was your what was your uh what were
your teenagers like
um I was emo
I honestly I thought you I thought you
were gonna say Nemo and I was like I
could see that you're right oh I'm
having trouble
okay so like imagine My Chemical Romance
but a person
eyeliner black hair no really big pants
and then you met your wife and she dyed
your hair blonde
I did do that
turns your life around you're seeing the
Sunny Side of Life the blonde side
everyone's better calling you sir
no we're from Michigan originally yeah
currently live in Florida oh you live in
Florida yeah
[Laughter]
so what's your song Gonna Learn to do
first go swimming in a swamp or yell
racial slurs to minorities
um while we're having a daughter
um so she well
the same question now
I would definitely go with the swamp
with a swamp really close to our house
right
and the one thing always people say
about Florida is like oh it's really
nice but you got alligators don't you
and you have crocodiles like that does
not factor into our lives because
crocodiles aren't even in America it's a
good point
wow she knows more about Florida than
you do and you're wearing a Gyarados
t-shirt thank you for noticing
I noticed
see this is what I'm saying if I had a
boy he wouldn't wear some [ __ ] like this
[Music]
so your son if he was acting like you
you'd be like no be better than me
we're a we're a Blastoise
I mean they're both the final evolution
so I'd be okay with it
[Music]
[Laughter]
are you are you making your own
bodyguard
hi
she's the 3D printer
so Marley yours your husband gave you
chlamydia and you still let him
use a pull out method without a condom
a round of applause it was
[Music]
it
that's nothing
was a while if you count the hours it
clears up pretty quickly
[Music]
how many diseases uh not like uh how
many STIs have you had
just chlamydia
just once
I have a pretty good idea
no
yes
is the immaculate chlamydia it just came
out of nowhere
so what are you doing to uh have safe
sex nowadays well I'm pregnant so you
can't get pregnant again while you're
pregnant I think you can
[Laughter]
yeah it is a daughter
[Music]
well just yesterday she's like I'm So
Pregnant I can't see my vagina anymore
so when you hear your wife say that
you're not like
I'm ready now you're like let me take a
look for you
and you chuckle in a creepy way
[Music]
and then you don't like what's happening
with the vagina she pointed it out and
then she posted it to a Facebook group
do I talk about your man boobs in public
do you have puffy nipples let me see him
no he don't I don't I don't
just big boobs
I cannot lie
well it's good to see the kid from Jerry
maguirel all grown up and getting laid
um so what do you guys do on dates do
you guys like go to a uh like a DND
conference
I'm not into that at all oh you're the
more traditional one that one's the uh
neurodivergent one
they just let him come in you
yeah that is true you know what a
What a symbol for just an optimistic
Life coming ahead and you're just the
two of you really gives me hope for my
future that I will be fine and single
maybe
but listen we've been on 13 cruises in
three years yeah that's a lot are they
Carnival hell no stop a Disney cruise
that's a requirement if you're in
Florida you have to go on at least 13
cruises and two do you know how much a
Disney cruise
I'll tell you what I would pay for it no
yeah that's different
he went so you were a childless couple
without even a kid there
yeah that's why we moved to Florida oh
we're Disney adults Disney adults
what's what's your favorite Disney
thing
when you say
yeah Princess and the Frog
oh do you guys
um cosplay in bed no Disney no vote me
in the eyes no
I see some real potential for that
though I think
sorry
yeah I wonder
it's Princess and the Frog he cried so
hard when the Firefly died
the only reason he cried when the
Firefly died is this that's because only
that's uh that's the only character you
could see
[Laughter]
a frog it's pretty bad
well give it up for Marley and
llamas Matt llamas
a married couple going on a date with
each other
we got a little glimpse into their
child's future
we got someone coming up
I know James Jackson let's get a look at
James Jackson
[Applause]
here he comes
James Jackson
I think that's how all men look
he's getting ready to murder someone
hi James Jackson how are you tonight
great
you've seen blue eyes beautiful man you
are
if only you had some hair that Marley
could dye blonde
you would be
medium
medium rare
well that's good you don't want to be
too obsessed with Disney
uh What uh what are you obsessed with
Marvel movies
you're just obsessed with chopping wood
and
working on your chopper
[Laughter]
it's not all my days
he's not good at talking with about his
feelings
what what do you usually like to talk
about what it what really gets your goat
liberals
it's my second language
oh that mic is not on
it
there we go
he's a man he knows how to work
he just doesn't remember how to turn it
on but it just takes time you know can't
open up when you first meet someone what
did you say you said uh takes time you
know no before that you're really into
uh talking about feelings talking about
feelings
how did you learn that skill yeah
[Laughter]
I feel happy that we're here together
yeah don't look at me hey I'm right here
too
oh
this guy is a homing missile he sees the
target he he goes for it
[Music]
well what are you looking for on a date
compatibility Good Times someone with
hair
someone with hair yeah yeah yeah
yep
well are you ready to meet your future
date yeah we got Julie G coming up
Julia gee here she comes
from the back
stairs are right over there
[Applause]
oh she's lost
but she's a woman she will ask for
directions
[Music]
I don't
think you're more of a One Direction fan
give it up for Julie G going on a date
[Applause]
[Music]
for 90 seconds starting now
hi Julie g hi remind me of your name
James J cool yeah James J Julie G very
cool yeah
compatibility there already yeah so I
walked in late
decided to put
I saw you do that
I have no idea what's going on I thought
you saw the first date and you thought
it went so well you're like I really
want to do this I was confused confused
are they really are you all together for
real okay oh yeah beautiful
congratulations congratulations yeah
so I'm here with my husband and my aunt
so this is a fun
fake date yeah I'm here with my two
homies
hello
and I'm just visiting Austin for the
weekend right beautiful I thought I
would go on a 90-second date you know
fun same I'm like give us some problems
what are we okay so we're chatting I
feel like we're being observed you know
I know it's like
just ignore them so what are you looking
for in a partner aside from your husband
much not much just him okay yeah yeah
but it's really nice to yeah meet new
people yeah all the time make new
friends
do you feel like you're leading me on
right now like what's happening I I
don't think so oh man
Austin for from where Washington DC
beautiful we're coming from New Orleans
and time give it up for Julie G and
James J
ush Julie G you brought your whole
entourage on this day you got [ __ ]
homies you got your husband you got an
aunt just
fun to like bring the crowd into the
conference
I [ __ ] hope not I really hope not I
also didn't know what I was signing up
for like
[Music]
so my buddy explained this is like we
were going on a date with you I didn't
know we were dating other people yeah I
thought it was just a fun improv I think
we were both misled and yeah I feel like
oh yeah no it's me yeah it's not you
so that's cool you got a husband you uh
you are not compatible but you're still
here
oh why not right
we've been married
like six months yes yeah I'm like I
thought you were counting the years
this is really not that serious
and a half days
you're barely married so this could go
either way and it's good to have backup
oh he just ran out the back [ __ ]
your husband looks like Anton chigur
from No Country for Old Men
are you are you safe
but I guess it looks like not a fan of
Classic Cinema
[Music]
it's a big strike in James Jackson's
book He's
big into the Marvel series
James what kind of movie would you take
uh This married woman on
a horror film yeah
yeah yeah I'm into that would you would
you sit like holding hands would you
comfort her are you scared like only if
her husband's okay with her you know
yeah but like yeah
[Laughter]
one of these days we're gonna have a
single couple up here
[Applause]
and then you've got YouTuber with him
you're all from DC
yeah uh no so we're visiting him and he
came with me so
and you guys are childhood friends
I'm making it up
[Music]
um with my aunt no it's okay with my
aunt and my husband yes okay yes do you
think that when you came up on stage if
they went to the bathroom and started
choking oh I don't know did you guys do
that that's kind of weird is that a
thumbs up oh [ __ ]
have you got laid here
no we were like playing Smash Brothers
and stuff yeah
just hanging out whoa this guy smashes
his brothers
37.
do you see a problem with that
if you were like I was smashing Brothers
but you're just playing a video game
um I don't know how to carry on that
company
this is the limit of
uh autism it really turns women off
I don't think that's a thing yeah sorry
yeah that's
what they call Casual Sex In The Hood
well yeah everyone has a Gyarados shirts
some people just wear it on the inside
you have an inner nerd uh
what is something nerdy that you do that
maybe you could be compatible on with
James something nerdy I don't know I
guess
I follow a lot of rules oh
all the rules except don't cheat on your
husband in public yeah I'm a real
straight shooter except for that one
[Laughter]
have it
[Music]
is this Bill Maher's new rules
oh you know just I don't like getting in
trouble so
have you had like one of those people
that goes to speed limit yes
yeah well
no that's not one of them I'm trying to
whoa what a badass
for Public Safety and he can tell
the feeling of getting caught you know
doing something wrong like like cheating
on your husband
cheat on my husband no
[Music]
no look how eager she was for that
Jesus Christ I love saying this okay
let's say you knew you weren't gonna get
caught would you steal
um
no no no no no no no no
okay another episode of how white is
this white woman
[Music]
stealing what about stealing from a
corporation
that just [ __ ] over at your letter I
mean yeah if there was a way to do that
and redistribute the wealth or power or
whatever it is
oh my God
what is she in the Weather Underground
[Laughter]
is this your new startup
no
I'm like a questioner so if a rule makes
sense I follow it and if it doesn't to
me yeah I don't unless the repercussions
for getting caught are high and how has
that been working out for you medium
medium were you uh did you have hair or
did you shave it all when you joined the
area and Brotherhood in prison
uh-oh my hair started thinning in
college and as soon as it happened I was
like I don't want to be one of those
guys who's like trying to
call yeah so 22 just knocked it all off
I never looked back I had to join the
gym
Jewish is it Jewish Jewish give it up
for her chosen by God
well I just figured sitting next
okay I don't know what just happened
there I think they made a bet Bank
transaction nervous if I was sitting
next to someone in the Aryan Brotherhood
nfts just went up two points
it's fun what's the most Jewish thing
that you've done
probably my bot Mitzvah yeah yeah how
much money did you get at your Bot
Mitzvah good amount yeah oh I I don't
know it was a couple thousand something
up there not knowing that accurate
amount makes you not Jewish yeah I
oh my God
and that's
used
and now I'm rich I'm not Jewish
not
[Laughter]
what a letdown
I don't think he's allowed I would
though
my husband's not Jewish no yeah it's
great
do you
look how excited he is
hahaha
he thought that was a compliment for
himself for some reason
caught that compliment in his little
Jewish claws
I don't know
um Julie uh Amy Says Jews have big dicks
do you think that you would have a big
dick if you were a man
cool do you have big dick energy
no no no
that she follows the rules yeah so no
that that's a no that's a no yeah I know
I have small I have I have safe medium
is short dick energy
maybe not sure I don't know humble
humble Dick Energy
she can say that
you know there's a rule in the in the
concentration camps about escaping so
I would put that in the past tense it
would make me feel better
[Laughter]
James have you ever been arrested or
been in jail no
oh what's the worst thing you've done
that's um that that we don't have to
call the police about
I follow those kind of rules and I don't
know I'm pretty square right okay
but like I'll like I'll like sign my
timesheet late you know that kind of
thing wow
white-collar crimes
give me a heart attack
so um do you guys seem like you guys are
very you know like normal
normal people
[Laughter]
like just not in the middle yeah what
riveting conversations would they be a
part of tell me what rules have you
followed recently Julie
everyone
[Laughter]
you guys are a
friend thank you
would you ever play Super Smash Brothers
I was just gonna say is that what we
would do play Smash Brothers we were
friends
Smash Brothers Smash husbands
they're they're part of it
uh just a lot of characters I don't know
I mean I played like 10 minutes this
weekend I made that up completely like
they played a lot but
so you didn't even play you were just
watching people play
Julie if you ever need a spectator we
got James over here he's good at
watching Brothers
I don't know
give it up for a Julie and James
thank you
they're gonna follow the rules and get
off the stage
Love A good rule follower let's pick a
girl first this time
we got Roxy coming on up here from the
front row
[Music]
[Applause]
with the primary colors
hello Roxy
hello
what brings you out tonight
I'm with my friends over here they
brought me
here's a very important question that a
lot of people have gotten wrong tonight
are you single okay I'm single oh my God
what a relief
yeah
the stakes are real she came to play
she's lonely
why uh why are you single
oh good question I'm super picky oh okay
what's something what's something that
you uh you know or like this this won't
do that you think is like unique that
other people wouldn't necessarily
catch as a red flag
I don't know if it's like an immediate
idiot that's like half my personality so
yeah what if they were more into TV
shows oh that's cool too okay yeah any
sort of media
yes
anything on the screen oh that's crazy
do you know uh you know No Country for
Old Men Anton sugar yeah
yeah that girl did it Julie and she's
married so it's been working out for her
being ignorant of culture
do you have any questions for uh Roxy
what's it like yes
um
like what do you like to do aside from
movies God that's I mean that like
hanging out with friends and like that's
me
um I do Edibles you do Edibles yeah do
you um do you like uh to dance I I'm
terrible at it but yes I do like to
dance yeah
say
[Music]
it's a good question that's a great
question that is a good question
what would your sign in your house say
right there
I couldn't agree more it's okay Roxy's
gonna be thinking about that for a while
uh because she's gonna get it home and a
white picket fence with our next
contestant is William gal
a big cheer comes from the table that
he's sitting at
he's taken the long way
okay
here he comes Williams down
I know will they get along
who will say something weird
90 seconds starting now
oh they said it's starting now okay
yeah me too okay what do you do for work
what do I do for work yeah this is
really exciting I'm an uh environmental
permit reviewer for the state of Texas
amazing I have no idea what that
straight over my head that's cool that's
cool what about you what do you do I
work for a production company
cool what do you produce TV oh that's
cool yeah that's cool yeah is there
anything that you do that you've worked
on that I would know
um probably but let's I yeah let's not
talk about that I have a friend that
works on like my or like my 500 pound
life or something oh yeah so my
co-workers around that show oh wow wow
we probably have some mutual friends
there the same people what do you do for
fun
um I mean I I do like Cinema and TV and
uh I also do like video games like uh
Smash Bros
I have not played I played Mario Kart
the other night that's cool that's a
video game yeah it is a video game
so what what kind of sign would you have
in your in your room
uh live laugh Tito's Handmade Vodka
Cheetos okay yeah okay
that's not very good but it's my only
answer it's very awesome yeah
I guess mine would be [ __ ] [ __ ] get
money
and time way to go William gow and Roxy
[Applause]
Lily going for the comedic points and
not the wholesome guy points on the last
question
interesting choice you uh gave her props
for knowing one video game
now uh can she give you props for
knowing your star sign
what is your stuff what is your sign
William GAO wait is she's supposed to
guess or am I supposed to tell her uh
why don't you guess Roxy I really don't
know much about this stuff yeah me
neither
assume that you'd be into that
foreign
cancer just because that's you think I
have cancer
I think she called you a cancer I said
your star sign he's just Asian he's
skinny that's how we all are
Hans knows no I I'm a Pisces I think
yeah I think
well I was born in March so I think
that's a Pisces March what second what
is that
okay I knew I knew about 10 women would
be like Pisces for sure
Pisces Rising
[Music]
I don't take too much stock in that kind
of stuff so you're more into the
The Zodiacs from China
oh yeah you're the monkey yeah oh but
that's important okay so because of
Asian pride you believe one fairy tale
but not the other I mean that's what
most people do right yeah I guess what's
your favorite Disney movie
Star Wars
is that Disney later never seen it yeah
it was a late add-on to the Disney oh
okay so some nerd [ __ ] that you probably
didn't know about she had to Google
Super Smash Brothers just now
uh and it [ __ ] is Mario
[Laughter]
she
and there's a turtle
there's a turtle
there's a lot of characters
um you obviously don't play a lot of
Super Smash no no I would say none I
don't play it I don't play it I'm not um
do you you know how when you play the
drums you have to use both hands and
your feet I can't
um do those things
with the thought you can't use both I'm
just bad at it at the yeah
how do you type both hands you don't
type in super for me just one I'm just
saying I just like uh oh you hunted back
it's both of the yeah I don't like it
no more video games guys
well luckily you're not on a date with
an Asian it's Roxy Who probably types
with two hands
yes
all right Roxy uh what do you think
about uh you know William Gowen his job
at the environmental thing for Texas so
obviously what do you do
I review environmental permits for the
State of Texas okay so obviously not
very good at his job
it wouldn't send me lose some you know
Texas is definitely definitely lost a
lot there yeah yeah what's your favorite
thing about the environment
it's still here
still here for now how much time do you
think we have left with that
good day or uh sure at least a day
hell yeah an expert on the subject it's
William GAO giving us another day
Roxy so you work at a production company
any uh advice for us here at the other
people dating show
oh I don't I'm yeah no wisdom okay well
we would like you to hire us for the TV
yeah produce us or whatever
you said that you have some friends that
work on the 500 pound life and then you
try to make a connection through that
that's cool you're like Hey we're the
only people that are like [ __ ] in
this TV show
how do you find the people for that TV
show do you just door-to-door
they're all in Houston
it's just true burn shots fired at
Houston
that's where the show is shot so
it's shot in Houston
huh
it's a Target Rich environment
do you guys both like your jobs
I do yeah
yeah
I don't know why I ask yes and no
questions it's okay
yeah whenever someone on my phone 500
pound life farts they have to call
William GAO to get a permit
[Music]
so uh I mean you guys
I love farts so [ __ ] much it's okay
sorry that was funny you didn't like it
and I I appreciate that I I like the
effort okay yeah thanks man what a dad
thing to say do you want kids
oh yeah yeah yeah do you want kids yeah
yeah it's a match
Jewish Matchmaker Amy Schenker
Roxy so uh What uh what do you like to
do in Austin
being with friends you could do that
anywhere anything specific
do you do you go on uh like paddle
boarding
no I'm not very like athletic just walks
it's about like just walked she likes to
[ __ ] walks perfectly suited for
walking do you walk at night
okay
just a lot of
you know she follows the rules like
Julie does are you a rule follower
I'd say for the most part yes and then
are you
yeah yeah for the most part I I I guess
I enforce rules yeah you enforced I mean
for yourself state employee
William GAO do you recycle
absolutely and everyone should
wow do you recycle women
like you know go back to and forth and
back and forth like that I mean I guess
I put them back in in the like
you know life cycle after I'm done with
them yeah what the [ __ ] does that mean
it does not kill I wrap them up like a
cocoon and then once they've liquefied
yeah I put them back into the [ __ ]
what do you think is the life cycle of a
woman
can you explain it to us in five easy
steps
um I'd say it's pretty much like the
life expectancy of a woman
oh my God that sounds so scary you're so
smart and you're using words like life
expectancy
what is uh what do you think what do you
think Roxy has to expect in her life
uh hopefully not a bunch of 500 pound
people in her life
hopefully a safe walk back home
rocks
Roxy have you ever uh dated an Asian man
before
whoa you're a chaser
watch out William she's a pervert she
has a fetish
how did you find an Asian man
hinge hinge yes
what do you say like that how did it end
up
oh I just hinge was the well okay how
long did you date
we'll um
not long at all three dates yeah
yeah
he left you he ghosted you he sure did
he uh what are you looking at me for get
your guys in chat
y'all are asking the questions he um
go blank oh he was dating a girl in
Costa Rica well we hate her
[Laughter]
damn time and oh oh okay and then and
then he goes to is he in Costa Rica
right now yeah
I don't know why don't you come on out
what a great excuse
that's gonna be my goat no I'm in Costa
Rica
that's where all Asian guys go to escape
beautiful white women
hey girl you just got
Hans with the subtlety
you know I'm gonna switch wigs with
William gal after this I'm gonna pull
the whole Prince and the popper oh God
William have you ever dated a Caucasian
lady
yeah yeah okay but it's just normal
every day walk in the park for you
literal walks in the park that's what
you do well I actually tend to like
match with fobby Asian girls on dating
apps so Woody Asian girls like fresh off
the boat oh okay Bobby
they got a fob for a Mercedes-Benz their
dad bought them
if they were rich I wouldn't mind it's
fresh off their boat
like they came here on there okay [ __ ]
all of you
this is the part where Amy turns on the
audience one time a show
we're gonna get some quality roasts uh
William so you uh you normally date like
Asian people and what is it like dating
a white woman what do you find different
about white versus Asian
uh go as racist as you can oh yeah I'm
about to go all in okay all right so the
Asian women that I do tend to date are
fobby and they don't really understand
me as well I feel like white women do
understand me better did you did you
grow up here yeah born and raised
so they speak English as your big
critique that is probably number one on
my list and then their biggest critique
of you would be I'm Asian okay yeah oh
you are Asian
so Roxy
um you love Cinema what's your favorite
movie
I have I have a lot that's a different
name but two
[Music]
Fantastic Mr Fox yeah and
yeah and about to inside bye inside
what Bo Burnham I just call it inside
nice inside okay
what's is that the one where they're
trapped in a room or is that the room
have you seen outside it comes after
it's the second one
yeah why don't you go take a walk more
instead of watching movies all your life
I don't know why I'm turning on the
contestants well that's cool uh William
what do you think about those two movies
Fantastic Mr Fox and this movie no one
has ever heard of called inside well if
it's inside my Bo Burnham yeah yeah oh
this is comedy special yeah his comedy
special it was really really a movie
yes everything two hours long is a movie
that's on letterbox it's on what it's on
letter
box it's on letterbox yeah
I don't know
are there other
characters in it
it's really just Bo Burnham it's just
him yeah yeah that's probably not a
movie it was really good though I I was
yeah it was great
yeah uh well yeah I'm not talking okay
William what do you uh what do you think
is most similar between you and Bo
Burnham are you also an angsty
liberal
oh yeah sure and we both spend a lot of
the time inside
that's weird considering your job though
yeah
it's the safest place yeah I stay away
from all the all the from all the
environmental regulations you let slide
do they pay you off
they do pay me
the off part is where the entry comes in
have you ever committed a crime have you
ever accepted a bribe
uh I cannot confirm nor deny that okay
look into that Texas
you have you committed a crime
no yeah yeah or no no you were right I
am right
gosh such a good person what's the worst
thing that you've done like like dropped
a baby on purpose
no I don't know I don't nothing really
do you ever wish people uh would die
no like specifically Asians in Costa
Rica
[Laughter]
if you guys could go back in time
who would you [ __ ] Mary kill
out oh you're right
well [ __ ] I wasn't ready for that
um
okay
what's that
oh they said um I was like who would you
[ __ ] [ __ ] Mary kill is a game where you
name three people and then you go I'll
[ __ ] him I'll marry him I'll kill him
and then I was like who would you [ __ ]
Mary kill if you could go back in time
and they were like give him [ __ ]
options [ __ ] and I was like you're
right I [ __ ] up
so that's where we are right now are you
two wearing the same shirt you and a
girl behind you or is that different
very similar wow
between those two and someone else in a
plaid shirt
one else is wearing a plaid shirt that's
impossible
that's amazing you guys Blended in a
Flocka Lululemon customers
um but anyways yeah would you uh who
would you [ __ ] marry or kill just in
general we gotta give names who do you
wanna who would you
who would you kill
if you could kill
which current U.S president would you
kill
accident would you kill
[Music]
I would choose that one yeah oh wow
you're from China dude relax uh
so William have you ever uh taken a date
out uh and somewhere specific in Austin
some Austin spots you could recommend
um yeah uh the the Mueller area is super
nice do you have a specific spot like
one corner or just like I don't know a
[ __ ] bar or a restaurant or a like a
yeah that that one uh
um Irish pub at Mueller that one's super
nice yeah that the Irish was called okay
like mix something of hands
what's your favorite drink
uh I like whiskey bake based drinks so
like an old-fashioned or a whiskey sour
what's your favorite drink was he sour
wow wow wow compatible you know what
this is the important we're finally
getting down to the nitty-gritty here I
think they're both alcoholics
and then oh God I can't have much
alcohol because I'm Asian
we know
yeah like Han's nose right like no
I'm Americanized I'm also Americanized
but my my jeans are all Asian mine
aren't
I don't know I could I could throw back
alcohol I don't get the Asian glow
I don't get red
guess you're not Asian then
oh I hope you guys fight
I'll fight you in Super Smash Brothers
how about that no no never mind
what a boring fight
do you play you play Smash Brothers you
would I
okay good are you from China with this
[ __ ] my family is so you're a Chinese
Texas environmental regulator two places
not really known for their environmental
regulations you know I was thinking that
earlier but I didn't want to say
anything
I'm just trying to give back to the
world
okay No One Believes you
laughs
everyone's suspicious all of a sudden
but what happens if you turn it this way
[Music]
this
way
Roxy what uh what is your favorite
environmental disaster
Chernobyl everyone says that one Exxon
Valdez spill
Valdez Valdez
golf
what you have one I was just gonna say
Pompeii because it's the only one I can
think of and it's far enough that like
No One's Gonna Be hurt if I say that wow
following the rules not offending anyone
what a safe answer yeah it's not really
an environmental I guess it's from the
environment but I was more thinking like
humans destroying the like human error
as opposed to the nature correcting
itself
um but yeah what does uh do you hate
Italian
who doesn't nature corrected itself
arrogant
uh that's cool so uh any cool historical
facts that you would like to share with
each other now
oh I have a question what is your
favorite both of you uh porn
areas
General vicinity of your favorite
subjects like what's your search
keywords stop pretending like you don't
know what I'm talking about never heard
of porn I don't know what you're talking
about never heard of porn
is that not environmentally friendly
okay he's not willing to answer Roxy are
you uh I just
can't well
you guys are
a match made in heaven I think
you guys are both grounded in reality
I like it I like it you don't seem
interested in each other at all but
I think she's nice
I think she's nice
you know what I say when I really like
someone they're nice
nice it's not they're good it's a real
neutral they're Pleasant what should I
say
um fire yeah or or like more specific
compliments like uh I like I like her
piercing are those green
eyes yeah
they they look into my soul yeah I mean
she has nice eyes don't take my
compliments
she has a nice smile oh that's good okay
well we already knew you were into her
dude
um
go give it up for Roxy and William gal
what I like to call the reverse Yoko Ono
situation
let's get a
bow
here
a hole
woman
we are right under a fan we got Michelle
human female
coming on up here she signed up just now
here she is about to get interviewed
we're gonna get to know a little bit
more about
this chapstick wielding
uh uh lady
of she seems great in the cave
she's slowly making her way up here yeah
yeah yeah very very careful real texasy
in the in the pace
hello this is the same speech he drives
at
no way are you kind of a Speed Demon
I've heard I have a love Lead Foot
Lead Foot lead left foot hold the mic up
to your mouth sorry
so uh what do you like about uh driving
fast
I don't know I've never really chosen it
I just tend to drive fast you're like it
chooses me speed chooses me you have a
Need for Speed
that's cool uh do you do speed the drug
do you do any uppers I don't
one of those rule followers we've been
hearing so much about tonight there's
rules for drugs yeah don't take a lot
be chill
so you don't do drugs which is good
because you drive kind of fast
so you're just doing this sober you're
just soberly driving like a maniac
probably better in case you get pulled
over you know have you been pulled over
did you get out of it most of the time
usually how many tickets have you hadn't
recently no lifetime
um probably like four or five oh that's
not bad yeah that's average yeah and I'm
like
27 so there's still time to up that yeah
I'm at like 17 I think
Amy is out of control out of control
this is an intervention
oh these cops
stop speeding
she's been living in New York too long
she's like do you like do you would you
ever ride a motorcycle
I think so that sounds fun I would never
own one but I think writing on one
sounds like a good time like on the back
would you you wouldn't drive okay and
about on the front yeah like a koala
bear turned around like Kim Kardashian
and Kanye's video would you do a video
like that I didn't I haven't seen that
oh okay well here's a very important
question Michelle are you single
I mean no uh no no
one of these like fakers
like it's only real in the zip he's
alive but
I would hope
how long have you guys been not together
well we're together he's just far away
you know where where is far if you say
Houston California are you from
California
don't say if you are just say no he's
trying to get out of here don't worry
about it everyone put away your
pitchforks
one of us
how did you guys meet we went to high
school together oh okay okay
damn wow
that's so true have you been dating
since high school no how long have you
been dating only like a year a year oh
okay okay so there's still time for her
to break up with them and find someone
else yeah we got dates tonight we got so
many men we can get William gal back up
here if you want
he does a great job he does have a good
job he's not good at it though could you
tell he was like bad at the job
yeah I think he's taking bribes he I
think he's just like check check
[Laughter]
what do you do I'm a recruiter
for what
um I'm in Tech I'm in Tech yeah I work
for procore construction software
does anyone need a job
well sorry I tried out of luck you need
a job lady you're hired you work at Pro
Tech now what is it called
yeah and we'll see you tomorrow
well let's try to break up her
relationship that's long distance we got
Louise mandra coming up with the Lewis
sweet skills
of Seduction
[Applause]
he walks faster yeah their pacing is
going to be off
he's going to talk your ear off nice to
meet you nice to meet you
happy Sunday hey how tall are you
actually I'm Mexican so that might be
pretty tall I'm I'm pretty much five
nine but I like to say I'm five eight
I'm five ten so yeah your parents won't
wear heels oh I'm from California so me
too we're from from Los Angeles
whereabouts I went to college in L.A oh
really I went to LMU it's like near
Marina Del Rey area on the west side
yeah I'm from the poor part I'm from
East Valley oh nice whereabouts just
east L.A like just like Silver Lake
yeah but more in east side I guess yeah
downtown area like 10 15 minutes from
there how long have you been here here
um like four days oh wow
yeah have you done so far oh damn
slipped on my car you've been sleeping
in your car yeah yeah I mean is
everything okay yeah everything's
perfect actually I'm happy here
California kind of sucks gas is cool
here yeah it's a lot cheaper I'm not
moving here by the way y'all I'm
sleeping in my car so I'm not gonna
bring your property taxes down or
whatever okay yeah
um how long are you here for I have no
idea I'm trying to move to San Marcos
actually okay that's not too far yeah
that's nice it's just about 20 minutes
yeah yeah I've been there so I might oh
I'm from I don't know if you know Davis
no I know Davis yeah I used to go to
school there but I didn't want to go
anymore you you dropped out of Davis uh
not technically almost okay yeah I'm in
the process of dropping out I guess yeah
um just wanted to try something
different be here instead of being in
school how old are you 21. college is
good yeah I'm gonna finish San Marcos
Texas State everyone Texas State and you
know having a degree is really helpful
oh yeah yeah well I mean I'm definitely
gonna get my degree I'm not thinking of
not kidding and time you give it up for
this
couple
you became networking I thought I
thought this was the beginning of a porn
you know I could help you touch up your
resume
I'm recruiting
I'm a pretty decent resume I'd say yeah
that's great that's good that's good I
liked all the places you guys named
something in common right East L.A
you kept saying East L.A she tried to
find out specifically I feel like I said
eastola I don't know bonus question the
Mexican part I don't know the whole
thing is Mexican exactly I don't know
how to pinpoint it you were like uh how
tall are you because I'm Mexican
there's a lot of white tall people out
here I've noticed that this is just
called white people the tall white
yeah I hate uh when I whenever I go to a
bar I order a tall white
sorry guys
[Music]
I apologize for that one
um but yeah you're Mexican
you're they were like we don't accept
your apology
you've been in Austin for four days and
you're actually trying to move to San
Marcos you know most people do not try
to move to San Marcos they end up I mean
if you live in your car can't you just
drive to San Marcos and live there in
your car live in San Marcos though it
seems like uh I sleep at the Crunch
Fitness in Round Rock
do you what about the Crunch Fitness I
sleep at the parking lot in the Crunch
Fitness just tell everyone what are you
doing
don't tell everyone where you're
sleeping they're going to come steal
your home
Hans you lived in a van I did live in a
van tell him it gets better uh don't
live in Round Rock
you're like circling the coolest part
just come right here yeah I'm always
here though so it's cool okay yeah well
it just is safer to sleep up there yeah
yeah shower place to stay
um I just don't understand commuting
when you live in a car well
like why would you drive all the way out
there well [ __ ] I gotta get gas for my
home what I use the gym I shower there's
gyms here there's gyms here yeah but I
just have the crunch fit like I have it
in from California so it works here is
that the only Crunch Fitness
um there's one like in San Antonio so
oh well yeah don't definitely don't go
there yeah no uh I swear to God if I
find an Austin Crunch Fitness
no it's not 24 hours that's why oh yeah
okay yeah not here not here yeah
yeah
so what was your name it's Michelle
Michelle so uh have you ever lived in a
car before
or have you been white this whole time
I've been White
that explains it I know white people
that have lived in their cars they've
been really nice cars though I will say
if you had to live in a car which car
would you live in yeah
I was in one recently and you can I I'm
tall and I can stand up full height yeah
you're five nine yeah they're Giant in
Mexico apparently my grandpa calls me
huge every time he sees me I don't like
it but it sounds like a schmuck yeah
he's a small man he's very sorry do you
call him small no
no do you call him old
you gotta call him something I just let
him call me huge and I'm like oh and be
like you old small [ __ ] and then and
then snuff him out with a pillow yeah
show him who's boss
okay
um so uh yeah Mexican man Huerta
his name's Lewis Louise is perfect man
Mexican man you're a superhero thank you
what are you gonna what are you gonna do
tomorrow day five day five actually go
check out an apartment in San Marcos I
have a job interview as well so for for
where good job well I actually you know
she's recruiting yeah are you recruiting
he does not listen
um Mexican men are still men I actually
had a job interview on Thursday for
Hayes County probation adult probation
so I went for that already what are you
gonna do like bail bondsman stuff no
it's just do you have to go to people's
homes and be like I think it's just like
a desk office like just you're like how
tall are you because if you're over five
nine I can't take you I'm not gonna mess
with you you wait what is the job
exactly I think just like assigning
people to their community service work
okay yeah okay have you done that before
um no but I've worked with my University
so it's fine
you've worked at a university with my
University yeah okay and community
service to people no I mean kind no so
you're but I'm gonna I guess facilitate
so these are violent criminals yes and
then you're gonna be like yeah okay yeah
sitting in that office
why just a range of different people
coming in or walking in coming out what
was the most interesting person
the most interesting person some dude
whose pants were like right here
well yeah I mean well I think your job
seems pretty safe if that was the most
interesting one
[Music]
um
well
yeah
best of luck with that interview you
have really lovely eyes
what the [ __ ] are they still on the date
he just goes he goes you have really
lovely eyes and he and she goes thank
you
that was sweet that was a moment a
little moment
I mean it's weird that you're shooting
your shot now when you had 90 seconds to
do it earlier
Michelle you said you wouldn't wear
heels is that a common thing you find
yourself saying
what if you meet some like giant giant
basketball player
that would be great would you wear like
would you wear like stilts I would just
wear some like
just some six inches do you not wear the
heels because you don't like them
shorter than you or because you don't
want to intimidate them
[Music]
you like feeling small
yeah well you are a woman
in Texas so you ever wear your heels
around your grandpa
actually I do yeah honestly I've gotten
used to it I wear heels pretty much like
all the time and
what a day to not huh yeah my
boyfriend's like five
tent he's honestly probably your height
oh nice oh he's like that's great
did you forget she had a boyfriend when
you complimented her eyes no just
okay just see him what he can do I like
that I like that compliment to
girlfriends we should we should set him
up with someone else so because he seems
like a nice person
who would you match him with
any of your friends over there I
okay
yeah that was my next move I mean it was
a good idea I'll say that
you're the other girl in the bucket well
she seems like she's uh down a day to
510 Mexico
yeah do you want to date this dude
almost has a job oh well he almost has
an apartment too and an apartment almost
to both you're almost I have a decent
savings account yeah yeah decent savings
account yeah you want to go on a date
with the man that can take it off
he's got chipotle money
come on up here with guac yeah look at
that do you know that I like this you
know I came with her oh no she came with
her what a mess you're together too
that's nice is she single
yeah I don't know okay she is single she
is should we do they both stay on stage
or is it yeah you have a boyfriend let
the Lonely People yeah you gotta go this
is for Lonely People hi hey 90 seconds
nice to meet you my middle name is
Louise
well because you're Louise it's just
l-u-y-s though oh I'm I got the whole
like Grandma
Luis yeah I was it was after my grandma
started the timer I'm not sure are we
dating already
yeah so San Marcos yeah uh it's an idea
it's an interesting uh Choice yeah just
a choice I don't know I'm still looking
around so cool so I like your piercings
they say a lot about you yeah thank you
um I do have a few
is that is that a problem no I love it
yeah I have piercings too but I lost
them I lose them all the time yeah
um
anyways so
what do you what do you like to do wait
do you have any hobbies Hobbies
um
I don't know just besides like working
out
um comedy I love comedy yeah what kind
of workouts are you like a hit guy like
CrossFit lifting regular lifting and um
oh cool what's your favorite lift my
favorite lips damn
bench press it's a regular lift what's
your max
I wish I knew it's pretty it's you'd
probably live more than me honestly did
you give it a shot you definitely left
more than me
um
so you like do you like with music or
anything of course what kind of music
you listen to music
depends large variety I used to be into
rap but slowly going more into just
I don't know anything that isn't too
crazy I guess like cool I don't know so
one time nice thank you give it up for
what was your name
Gabrielle Gabrielle and Luis
how does it feel when a girl says oh
that's my middle name
that's never happened but I figured
because usually when I go to a
restaurant they spell it Louise or Lewis
so you're used to people [ __ ] up here
now yeah so I figured it wasn't ouys you
know I feel like you uh got along better
with uh Michelle over there so is there
is your thing like girls with boyfriends
yeah I think I'm definitely into that so
is it the
you know that this woman just came on
stage to because she's single and was
like I'll go on a date with them and
you're like where's that taken [ __ ]
yeah now I kind of Wonder like what's
wrong with me like that I could not say
it's wrong
you all got new feedback for me
I think that um you do seem competitive
which I like though you're like how much
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was cool I can now bench you you
[ __ ]
what's your max what's your tattoo on
your leg
it's a dagger oh right
right that's my test I was there I was
there oh nice yeah well stay in the game
man you still have a chance why'd you
get a dagger
because I thought it looked cool
is that your only tattoo no I have a an
XO on my arm for Elliott Smith my
favorite Elliott Smith Elliott Smith he
definitely didn't get that because that
was cool no
Elliot Smith I wanted it to be a
different dagger
I like the Stagger no I know I like that
one and then I have a this like uh
tattoo my back of a matchbox like it's
like pretty big and it's got this like
hot lady on it oh a matchbox with a hot
lady I like that nice he's like is that
is that Michelle on there
I thought Obama like Michelle Obama for
some reason I don't know why and then
you have piercings but they're they fell
out I lose them all the time you lose
your piercings yeah I have more
piercings I bench more so maybe maybe
you could totally beat my ass I'm into
to that too oh he's into that I like you
I bet you like to be tied up in a closet
and forgotten about for days
just anticipating when they'll come back
yeah that's called Mexican daycare
exactly how much experience do you have
with the cartel
I feel like you'd like them
I feel like you would like them I would
yeah do you um abuse men or
um yeah I wouldn't yes it's fine I don't
I don't think so okay because he likes
it I was just saying like that that
would be I would be a thing she gets a
she gets a ring on her ear for every
heart she breaks
[Music]
that dagger is the first guy that she
was like [ __ ] you
I like it I like you're trying to hang
up a shower curtain on your head wait
what do you bench
um
I haven't done like
benched for like Max in a while but my
Max has like I think like 145 which
isn't that 145 yeah
[Laughter]
it's like a while ago I now I try to
stick to like higher up if Louise falls
on you you can barely get him off
she could bench you almost cut off a
foot yeah I don't really lift anymore a
mortal Runner now oh me too actually I
run all the time cool which is crazy I
like running like at 1am though is that
weird oh uh no I'm more of like a normal
time runner yeah I'm not well girls just
can't run at night because of the
killings and rapes yeah
well uh I actually recently read an
article that if you have like a lot of
tattoos and piercings you're like less
likely to be a target for trafficking I
mean that's quite an investment yeah
unless they have a magnet
come on
is that why you go
is that why you got your piercings as to
like uh ward off right and another one I
actually did all these myself you did
that's safe that's good
um is that your job what do you do oh I
actually work in philanthropy
philanthropy yes what kind what is that
I'm a community engagement manager and I
work with foundations to help them build
capacity in communities
hmm build capacity and Community yeah I
like small non-profits they don't like
have a ton of staff so it's kind of hard
for them to build capacity and raise
more money so we help provide them with
resources and such okay okay she's a
giver yeah that's why she takes from the
dates you know it needs to filler the
balance
that's cool when was the last time each
of you went on a date on like a date
date
oh I'd say like last week last week in
California in California yes and then
you ghosted her no we still talk were
you like I'm leaving though oh yeah she
knew I was leaving okay did you um did
you guys stop
through it
[Laughter]
it's Yiddish
don't be culturally insensitive answer
the question
the last day I went on
um I don't know how long ago it was but
he made fun of me for pronouncing
laissez-faire wrong and then told me I
should read Infinite Jest so wow a real
life redditor we can jump him uh so did
I sleep with him I'm not gonna answer
but
it uh yeah so well you know Tech Bros
need some love too
have you guys read Infinite Jest anyone
in here want yeah
actually out of curiosity I did start
reading it I'm on page 400. I thought
you were gonna say four four quit
rocking through it well I had to know I
felt left out he explained it to me for
like an hour oh that sounds like a fun
date
[Laughter]
and you're still reading it that's good
yeah are you reading it because you want
to hit him up about it or are you
reading it because you're you're
genuinely interested in the book well it
it kind of sounded like I was interested
in it
um I have no plans to hit him up maybe I
should no no I don't think so he's in
jail he's in Romania he was like a
condescending and rude
well I actually kind of like the books
so that's okay that's good you should
tell him about it I think I'll pass
it only because it's like it's not
really uh are you into it though yeah
but I don't I don't want to talk about
it yeah but if you're into it I'm
interested uh yeah that's so cute that's
the nicest thing if you're in it if you
like it I want to hear about it I read
books too what's your favorite book I
mean we don't need to start lying you
know
what's your favorite book oh as of right
now I'm reading the war of art oh cool
so you like fantasy stuff no it's not a
fancy it's like non-fiction the war of
art yeah oh are you that the kind of guy
that reads like non-fiction grind set
books uh you know like a few of those
you know I'm talking about like Malcolm
Gladwell I don't know who that is but
yeah oh she just gagged at that I don't
know who that is who smells it's like
the kind of books that are like yeah you
can get through life at the top you're
you can be special if you put your mind
to it
a little bit a little bit I like Kevin
Hart he had a nice book no cool yeah
yeah he had a great book actually is
that Kevin Hart's book yeah is that
about being on top and get through life
on top no wait doesn't Kevin Hart suck
whoa I thought Kevin Hart was like I
mean asked his wife but that's not okay
who doesn't it happens I think I like
Kevin Hart yeah yeah his book is great I
want to say he sucks I would say he's
like he's bad at comedy but yeah he
started off really well he's a pretty
good rap I think he declined he has way
too many movies like Mark Wahlberg
Kevin Hart's in movies so many movies he
and Mark Wahlberg have too many movies
way too many movies right do you notice
do you have Netflix I don't give a [ __ ]
okay I respect that I respect so you
like like non-fiction um I recently
picked up um actually I stole this book
from Target
um still from Target they tally up your
[ __ ] and when you get to a certain
thousand thousand I think yeah no I
think it's more than a thousand just
based on what I don't know but stuff but
it's fine
um it gives me something to talk about
at least right uh it's called it it ends
with us I'm like on page 12 though it is
oh yeah Colleen Hoover yeah is it good I
don't know I would never touch the
Colleen Hoover book but I know that that
I've heard my mom's writing about it
yeah is it good
yeah
yeah
all right thank you so much
Michelle they're on a date all right let
it [ __ ] go you had your chance yeah
lady could have broken up with your
boyfriend on stage Do You Wanna really
nice smile
thank you that was nice
what was nice he said I have a really
nice smile oh good that's good we told
the other guy earlier to say did you
steal his line
no I wasn't here for that
okay well any more generic compliments
it was genuine I like your uh collar
I just I brought a limited amount of
sweaters so this is all I had to work
with whatever could fit in my car you
look great what kind of car do you have
a 2008 Honda Accord same oh I like that
I have like a 2010 Jetta so it's like
wow you guys could put it together and
build a community
good thank you yeah
it's nice yeah
um any advice for this guy living in his
car
[Music]
follow your dreams thank you thank you
his dream is to live in San Marcos
what's in San Marcos
so for um to apply to UT Austin you need
like a 3.0 so I got like a 2.9 so I'm
like all right it's fine yeah you were
like now all right yeah I have a lot of
friends who went to Texas State and they
liked it yeah right
they also have a really cool like River
or something you think you can like get
drunk and float down it do you think you
guys will grab a drink after this yeah
um I'm really hungry so I'm probably
gonna get food after this okay I don't
mind
give it up for Gabrielle and Luis
they're actually single
hey they hugged each other I like that
there was almost no chemistry in that
house
they're gonna be a part of a uh young
adult
film
yeah I feel like that could be the case
The Princess and the Frog
the Mexican and the goth girl I don't
know I don't know about that one oh is
he signing up look at this well it's
unfortunately the show is over
but timing is everything yeah you uh
could have worked up your courage an
hour and a half ago
but yeah we do it every Sunday if you
want to come back
there's someone for everyone and we're
gonna go allegedly reaching into the
bucket find
people for you to date next week
are you here next week
[Music]
first of all we gave Gabrielle get your
goddamn tone sir secondly
yeah Hans yeah how do we give Gabrielle
away
every one person
did you race him to be like this
well try again next week thank you for
coming man he's so upset look at him so
sad
anything you want to say before we leave
um
no okay give it up for Amy Shaker guest
tonight my name is Hans Kim thank you so
much good night
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]